[Musique]
alors que 2021 est sensé pour tous les
français être une année d'espoir pour
plusieurs secteurs ce début d'année
commence dans l'inquiétude et le flou le
plus total
je fais référence aux restaurants salles
de spectacle ou encore le cinéma qui ne
savent toujours pas quand ils pourront
rouvrir
et pourtant ils ont déjà bien souffert
en 2020 le début de la campagne de
vaccination contre la corrida a été
désastreux pour l'image de notre pays
alors que notre compteur restait
péniblement bloquer les français médusés
regardez leurs voisins se faire vacciner
en masse pire nous apprenons même que
votre organisation logistique risquer de
gâcher jusqu'à 30% des doses
réceptionnés et que de nombreux hôpitaux
manquaient déjà de seringue pour la
vaccination
trop c'est trop vous êtes un moment sur
les masses et les sacs du traçage des
personnes testées n'ont dû donc pas
suffit à vous hisser à la hauteur des
enjeux
nos concitoyens s'interroge sérieusement
sur vos capacités à gérer la crise
sanitaire
nul besoin de faire appel à un cabinet
de conseil américain ou à 37 citoyens
tirés au sort pour comprendre que vous
êtes dépassé le début de campagne de
vaccination par sa lenteur et ses
dysfonctionnements est un échec
mais tout peut encore changer avec la
mobilisation de tous mais faut-il que
les députés soient mieux écouter
considérer consulter associé à vos
décisions car nous représentons ici
l'ensemble des français
faut-il que les maires et présidents de
communautés qui connaissent bien leurs
concitoyens soient les partenaires
naturels de la compagnie final ils ont
déjà prouvé leur réactivité leur
efficacité équipements moyens humains et
matériels sont à votre disposition et
les régions après les masques et les
tests sont prêtes à mettre leur savoir
faire et leurs compétences logistiques
au service de tous
profitons-en nous parlementaires nous ne
sommes pas tirés au sort de façon
anonyme et irresponsable
nous rendons des comptes à nos
concitoyens nous relayons leurs
légitimes interrogations
or à vous entendre monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le ministre
tout va toujours très bien tout va très
bien avec les vaccins
tout va très bien avec les aiguilles
tout va très bien avec la stratégie
mais si tout va si bien pourquoi à
l'heure actuelle 20 % des français ne
sont-ils pas vaccinés comme en israël
pourquoi deux millions de français ne
sont pas vaccinés comme au royaume uni
ou au minimum 500 milles comme en
allemagne
pourquoi ne pas vous appuyer sur les
élus locaux sur l'intelligence de nos
territoires pour optimiser la conclusion
vaccinale et ainsi prévoir un objectif
bien plus ambitieux pour l'été le
premier ministre la réalité que toute
l'économie de la montagne est confiné à
noël les hébergeurs pharmacie supérette
conciergerie commerces de bouche
magasins de sport et de souvenirs ont
perdu plus de 80 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires habitués notre jeunesse est
menacée d'un déclassement inédit mais
surtout d'une menace bien plus grande en
effet donc j'étais en dépression
nous risquons de voir s'éteindre en aux
jeunes la lumière de la vie et de
l'espoir
la politique conduite par votre
gouvernement matière d'écologie s'arrête
bien souvent aux grandes déclarations
stampe au discours place aux actes
et pour cela nul n'est besoin de
modifier la constitution
tout juste il faut avoir de la volonté
politique
sur l'année écoulée selon les propres
chiffres de votre ministère les
violences ont augmenté de 8% dans les
zones rurales et périurbaines
quand dans le même temps elles ont
diminué de 5% dans les zones urbaines le
constat est sans appel les réseaux
sociaux sont devenus un élément
essentiel pour s'exprimer aussi les ca
des entreprises le soin de censurer ou
pas sur la toile constitue une atteinte
grave à la démocratie dans la mesure
nous n'arrivons pas à contrôler la vente
et l'achat de ces articles
pourquoi ne pas réserver visage des feux
de divertissement aux seuls
professionnels comme c'est déjà le cas
pour les mortiers pour éviter que chacun
puisse tirer de son jardin
[Musique]